[Musik]
[Applaus]
natürlich bin ich bauer um die welt zu
ernähren wir leisten einen kleinen
anteil daran um einnahmen dieses felix
kamera ständig harmonie pharma die
weltbevölkerung wächst allein in diesem
jahr rund 80 millionen menschen also
muss die landwirtschaft sich sehr stark
wandeln werden dieses thema mein ganzes
jahr begleiten
wir werden aber auch schauen während
endeffekt wenig ernährt welche länder
welche länder wovon ich länder
kontinente und menschen die heute und in
zukunft
wir schauen auch auf die landwirte
selbst bleibt über einem jahr zwei
landwirte einen klassischen
afrikanischen kleinbauern und sagen wir
und einen durchschnittlich großen bauern
in deutschland wir werden die frage
stellen was eigentlich die grundlagen
sind für die ernährung der menschen in
der gegenwart wie die ernten steigen
können wie sich landwirtschaft
verbessern kann nicht nur sondern sweat
laut dem sinne dass immer mehr mehr gern
gehört sucht man in der vergangenheit
getan hat natürlich muss die
landwirtschaft auch viel intelligenter
haben
die frage ist wie das ganze
umweltfreundlichen umweltverträglich
boden verträglich und nachhaltig
gestalten
[Musik]